it's not often you get to see yourself
portrayed in a movie so what does Apple
co-founder Steve Wozniak think of the
jobs film he is with me now here in the
studio thank you so much for stopping by
you saw the midnight showing last night
I'm sure you were really interested to
see what was going to be on screen what
did you think well I figured whatever it
was I probably disappointed I have high
high hopes and I didn't want to talk to
press so I went to midnight showing so I
could be alone and and what I thought
well you know what I had one of the most
entertaining nights of my life last
night because I saw a branding Carlisle
concert before the movie oh okay well
what about the movie the movie was mild
in my mind it was I thought the acting
was great for the roles they were
assigned I don't think the movie covered
the subjects when you cover when you
make a movie about something that's real
in life you can never get it like really
the personalities right because you
don't know how to read about a lot of
the the smaller personalities you cannot
get it right but the concept of each
scene what it implies should be right
and there were a lot of things wrong
that I knew for myself with Steve Jobs
and other people's relationship with
Steve Jobs in those days it was not like
that when Astrid referred to opens have
been a great attribution to Apple that
was correct and openstep was when Steve
Jobs came back mature enough to execute
and know what was good and what was
valuable and could sell and make the
company something they did not bring
Apple to a higher valuation than they'd
ever got to with the Apple to the only
product we had making money for the
first 10 years the entire time frame of
the movie was only was really the Apple
2 you know and and so the Steve Jobs the
movie covers a whole period that doesn't
fit what Aston's talking about the iPod
was Steve Jobs as Apple 2 that was a
great great product and it was due to
that that incredible focus and care
about the consumer and getting the right
product and that was great and that was
equal to the Apple 2 in value in dollars
as well as you know its meaning to the
world of course we had to go open and
open it up to Windows we didn't say you
have to have a Macintosh to use iTunes
for example so what do you think was the
biggest mistake in the movie what was
the most misleading thing about it I
think it was really Ashton has too much
of this this fan thing like a cult
leader and oh my gosh Steve Jobs has
always been
the great top people and could not see
that he was he had a lot of flaws in
knowing how to run things and execute
and make products that were worthwhile
during his fine men so you're saying the
movie over glorified sure yeah he didn't
talk about a lot of things when Steve
was was it made it look like he's forced
out of the company for no good reason
and it doesn't get into what the reasons
really were they didn't talk to any any
of the people on it you know what was
really going on in the company that was
bad at the time and you know you have to
realize that Steve kept trying to make
his own computer my Apple 2 took two by
the way he didn't take me to a homebrew
Computer Club you know I had been there
there were people in the club that had
my computer that I've helped them build
that were using it I've given it out for
free to everyone before Steve even knew
it existed so this was these kind of
things are all phony like he's the one
directing all of the wisdom and
intelligence and it was really coming
from other people he was a good filter
for it is better in these fine frames he
failed with the Apple three he failed
with ELISA he failed with the Macintosh
people don't know from that movie how
deeply the Macintosh failed how deeply
our stock slid down have we had to
regroup quickly and read and build a
Macintosh market over three years while
we had huge revenues from the Apple 2
and how Steve was trying to kill the
Apple 2 in a lot of ways and do very
unfair unrealistic things to it that's
not known there are obviously so many
twists and turns to the Apple story that
I think would be impossible to get in a
two hour movie let's talk about Aston's
portrayal of Steve did he get that right
I actually liked his portrayal of it and
I felt it was a good choice to pick
somebody who was into technology you
know it's just he didn't understand he
wasn't there living those times or I
think it would have been a lot of things
would have been portrayed very
differently and I don't know it was the
producer I think Astron was probably in
a producer role as well in coming out
with how Steve should treat other people
what did he do right like like that was
very hot there were very good
intelligent people that were that were
did not deserve the demeaning character
that he put on a Mike Markkula
who funded us he was Steve's mentor he
was the one that taught Steve how to run
and build a company
it wasn't vice-versa you know wasn't
like Steve's working the deals on this
guy who's been around the block for you
know a lot of times
Jen over glorifying Steve Jobs or has
the world over in the toilet in the time
frame that people are interested in the
early days of the company
yes he's over glorifying him and not
getting to the truth and it's based upon
the great Steve Jobs that came back
mature capable of executing that means
actually accomplishing visions Steve had
great vision of things like the
Macintosh by the way in the movie they
showed Steve like so important and jef
raskin running our Macintosh group has
been kind of nothing Jef raskins the one
who took us to Xerox PARC Center he's
the one that had been you know taught
classical music in universities as well
as was a technician he brought human
versus technology human over technology
in the Apple and into the world and he
was treated like so Shapley in the movie
no I didn't like seeing a lot of people
I know not get the respect they deserve
in their relationship of really giving
Steve Jobs the goods what about Josh
God's portrayal of you it's not on when
you get to see your house playing in the
way I think the way the routine the role
was written there were a lot of things
in there never happened me leaving Steve
Jobs you know and saying something but
but I think he played it very well yeah
I think he acted well I was glad they
chose a good actor as a matter of fact
most of the actors in there I thought
did a very good acting job and that
means a lot to me when I see a movie it
just something about it wasn't a story
of one strong conflict and suspense
you're waiting for the end that really
got to me that made me you know want to
recommend it more than mild
entertainment ok and I did laugh at
places on boy I'd boy did I laugh when
they made a joke about I was carrying my
own weight because I was skidding back
in those days but I laughed because I
liked good jokes it's good humor I even
laughed when I told some polish jokes
well good I'm glad there are some
light-hearted moments in the movie Steve
you have been talking nonstop through
the break about this you are so fired up
about it you think that the movie got a
lot of things wrong and yet Ashton
Kutcher has said you didn't consult on
this movie why not you were offering
they offered to have you come in it
would salt with them and tell them more
about what really happened but you
decided not to why not sure I got an
early script I read it my wife read it
and we were kind of abhorred by it and
if somebody else has started a creative
process of designing something writing a
script you don't come in and oh push
them out and I'd be this way there's no
way you can correctly
a hard job secondly I just did not like
certain things in that script at all
some because they were so wrong from the
truth
why not nothing they're wrong why not
tell them I have a very busy life and it
came at a very busy time in my life when
I traveled the world giving speeches
hardly ever home so I also had a busy
time but there they want to pay money
and so did the Sorkin film right so
you're consulting on Aaron Sorkin's film
which has not has not bought idols it's
in probably I'm consulting and you know
what there's as far as I know there's no
script written in other words they will
take the input the input from the
firsthand sources and create a script
from it rather than first hand towards
coming in can you modify our script a
little here and there that wouldn't work
that was I don't know is that magic you
know you know what you know what some I
saw a trailer about the Astra Kutcher
film and it was so wrong and backwards
of Steve directing something towards me
when it was really the opposite in real
life and you know what my comment about
that and he headline said that I said
the movie was crappy I never said that
once because I don't say it till I see
it and and so Ashton Kutcher said that I
was saying the movie was lousy because I
was being paid by the other one you know
what I don't do things my principles
aren't affected by money in the movie
you'll see that there were a whole bunch
of people who helped us start this
company hung around the garage and all
those people got Steve drawed in the
movie Steve Jobs it was really not Steve
Jobs himself said they don't get any
stock and we have to talk get all of it
so you know what I did I took my stock
and I gave them huge blocks I'm right
you gave people your own stock we knew
that story really well what words you
have for Ashton Kutcher what would you
like to say to him you know what I'm
really easy to get a hold of he could
Atkins he could have called me and
consulted over the phone anytime I got
from Daniel Kottke who's a star in the
film and a consultant I got the email
address of his management company to
email him to tell him I had not said
that the movie was lousy because I
hadn't seen it you know and I never got
an email back so so what was Steve Jobs
really like how visionary was Steve Jobs
he was he always took the role of you
have to somehow think higher level
thoughts and put this eret mystique on
which is vision and it's got to be
integer vision accurate he was not that
good at executing in other words coming
up with a vision that was makeable into
today a product that people wanted
enough that a company could be to make a
profit on it
he wasn't until he returned then he was
more stable and exercised and into the
operations of a company and with he
understood well he was a visionary
before no he was a visionary with with
the Macintosh machine this was the
future you know what there were a whole
bunch of us that were the visionaries
jef raskin who took us there and fill a
Kansan and we all saw it and said oh my
once you have this you'll never go back
how can we make it in a price it can
sell the Lisa costs twenty thousand of
today's dollars ten thousand dollars
then it's shown in the movie that's too
much for a personal computer if you wait
a few years the prices come down and now
it's affordable and we kind of gave
Microsoft the idea to do it once it was
affordable Eve do you think Steve Jobs
gets too much too much credit oh no I
never try to think that no well
sometimes in some areas he gets credit
for what other people deserve but you
know what no he actually um he actually
seems to be um I don't know maybe he was
trying to orchestrate being everything
seems to come from him when it came from
large groups of people he acknowledges
everyone really he was always very
friendly and nice to me so I'd say no I
think he's the greatest technology
leader of our of our lives I think he
did a lot to improve my life and your
life and deserves that credit yet you
say Ashton Kutcher got a lot of things
wrong that's for the early stage that's
when Steve Jobs came back to Apple from
that point on yes he knew how to execute
how to run a company and how to make
products that people wanted and that
we're good and it was still some time
before he had that big success with the
the iPod and it was going open so I know
so I I really admire Steve Jobs I just
don't think the movie is is accurate the
way it portrays his relationship with
others in the break I asked you if you
read Walter Isaacson's book and you said
you hadn't you don't read Apple books
why not I read them in early days and
they always had the early start of Apple
so wrong so missing the important facts
I mean if you want to see how to be a
young technologist and come up with
ideas to build products that will change
the world read my book I was that's one
of them it may not apply to this day and
era but it'll give you a lot better idea
I think the real secret is having good
technologists who are very skilled and
can create new great things and up on
all the latest parts and abilities to
use them and think out ways that have
never been done before like me
and have somebody like Steve Jobs who
wants to have a business and wants to
drive a business and make the phone
calls and do the paperwork and get other
people interested and bring them on
board and speak to the public so that
was a really good combination so you are
consulting Ron Terrence are Apple to is
half Steve Jobs I mean he was in heavily
involved in driving it to the public and
giving it a reason for being and
marketing and a lot of that stuff right
I want to talk about Aaron Sorkin's
movie because you are involved at that
movie so far how is that going what can
you tell us about the project and what
sort of input you've given them and what
have they asked you yeah I can't
remember but I I talked openly when they
ask questions I give them filling as far
as they want to go and I'll meet as many
times as they want and I'm just at their
service I do not know if I'll see the
script before the movie I will not
comment on the movie until I see the
movie I just I don't know if it's gonna
if I'm going to feel I go to a movie and
you know even if I hate the story and
it's untrue I could still be very
entertained
I wasn't entertained by the Kutcher s
Jobs movie but I could have been very
entertained if it's interesting I'm
following I want to see where it goes
and what I love pirates of Silicon
Valley that way I don't know really you
know yeah it was a shitty movie should
the rest of us see the movie should the
rest of you see the movie I can't answer
I don't give people direction in life
I'm not one of the people who says I
know what you should do and you should
do it my way or something like that
I'm close to the movie so it was good
for me to see it I felt good seeing
people I knew they weren't portrayed
like they really are but I know the real
people and you've talked to other Apple
employees what have they said so far um
well some of them one said one said he
wasn't going to watch the movie because
he didn't want to see a fiction he knew
from questions that they've been asking
him about things that were going to be
in the movie that never happened and
there were so many of those so we've
been talking a lot recently about
innovation at Apple today and there are
critics out there who are saying
innovation at Apple is in trouble do you
agree with that I don't agree with that
because you have to give things a long
time to really really be seen you'd have
to say innovations not alive with Apple
compared to
other companies now first of all the hot
products that Steve Jobs really got
behind inspired focused on and produced
like the iPod and the iPhone the iPad
those kinds of breakthroughs don't
happen every year so I give Apple some
time to come up with something so new
and major that's out there it's hard to
think you know of what new what
categories are left how much time do we
give them how much time do we give them
mm-hmm you know I'm glad I'm not a
businessman I'm a technologist you know
it's very I but I appreciate the very
the difficulty that businesspeople have
in bringing products to the market that
it takes a lot of time and and just to
build a market and you know there's two
categories one is a the the prolongation
of the iPhone where does it go from here
what are the new steps how could an
iPhone look different act different be
different have different user interfaces
are there different input and output
methodologies that will come along those
are usually the changes that we call
revolutionary that apples are you know
big head-on and they usually do it by
keeping things secret I don't know what
Apple is doing because it is secret
right and that's good for Apple
so let's one last question let's talk
about a guy who is a businessman and a
technologist Larry Ellison recently said
that we saw Apple with Steve Jobs go up
and then go down without Steve Jobs then
we saw it go up when he came back and
now he says it's going back down does it
keep going down is it going down um I
don't think of it that way I think that
Apple throughout all time even long
before Apple's real horrible times when
everybody said they might go broke and
the press got against us the stock would
go would go in half in a few you know a
few weeks are not just about the stock
I'm talking about the decline of
innovation yes and people will always
blame it on lack of innovation when
things are are are down turning in terms
of the company valuation and gotta look
out and do things and it's it's it's
still there's time to tell this I
wouldn't I wouldn't judge Apple as being
out of the innovation sphere yet I see a
lot of things going on in the world and
I always want Apple to be the leader
but sometimes Apple has the bigger
surprise than anyone
all right well time will tell Steve
Wozniak Apple co-founder so great to
hear straight from you what what you
thought of the movie what you think of
Apple today always great to have you
here on Bloomberg West thanks for
stopping by it was nice to talk to you